everybody's kind of getting into the
groove of it it was less of a getting
back on the bike and riding like
yesterday and everyone kind of remembers
how to snowboard now you know we're
finding out which boards and skis work
better on varied terrain azir boards
that work really well in the slush or
the powder but then just sketch right
out as soon as you hit ice and then
you're on your butt there's other boards
that transition perfectly it just hold
their edge you don't have to do any
adjustments and most of the boards where
you can just fly
there was a park day it was awesome you
spend the majority of the time at the
terrain park we hit the rails we hit the
jumps and two or three runs for grabbing
rotating again and nobody took any
really bad diggers so yeah it was
excellent I know I won't have tough for
tomorrow